all right if you're feeling cramped and
isolated at home try spending time
aboard the International Space Station
NASA's Peggy Whitson did that for longer
than any other American she spent six
hundred and sixty-five days in space
including a stretch lasting more than
nine months earning her the nickname the
space ninja Peggy Whitson the space
ninja joins us now for some practical
advice on handling isolation from her
home near Austin Texas Peggy Whitson
good morning good morning how are you
folks doing you're way better at it than
we are yeah well it's actually very
doable but it's very important to be
able to interact well with the people
you're you're staying with you're living
with and interesting a lot of people are
trying to work from home and trying to
be parents from home and have a family
at home and so it becomes very
challenging but that's just like what we
did onboard the International Space
Station our space station crew became
our family in orbit and we had to not
only work with them all throughout the
day but we couldn't go home at night we
stayed there on board the station and
had to interact as well and so it became
something that we did on a routine basis
and I think those interactions are very
important and we actually train our
astronauts to improve those skills
because we want everyone to play well
with others the space station because
you don't get to pick your crew you're
just gonna be up there and you have to
make the best of whatever situation
depend on each other so yeah and it
certainly feels like your life depends
on the people in your household right
now getting through the day as the hours
roll by so as people feel Restless just
like you can't go to a bar when you're
up there on the space station we can't
go to a bar down here on earth anymore
so what do people do what are those
skills that can be applied to everyday
life to kind of get through this well we
call them expeditionary crew skills but
they include things like team working
group living and
recognising that the team purpose is the
most important and Kovan 19 gives us a
very higher higher purpose much like
being in space does because we are
saving lives by quarantine II and so it
is important to understand that bigger
purpose and to embrace that purpose to
give you reason and rationale for
continuing to put up with the situation
and then there's the the actual
interactions that you do with the people
that you're living with and you have to
be able to communicate effectively for
most that is the most important thing
you have to be able to do and so that we
always have these ideas that we think
we're communicating and we have to make
sure that that's actually our intent in
our head is actually being communicated
Peggy what if there are no others to
play with other than yourself because
I'm sitting here thinking I never get
bored when I'm at home normally I never
get bored when I'm at home but just
knowing that I couldn't leave the house
all of a sudden my apartment seemed very
boring did you ever get bored in space
number one when you were there and what
advice do you have for people that don't
have others to play with well that's
that's a really good point Gail I think
that first did you ever get bored and
spur and board the space did you ever
get bored not really yeah yeah I think
not really because I always had the
option to look out the window and it was
always an amazing view down here down
here the other thing I always used to do
is Tesla sigh make make them I would do
the extra extra work that I've been
thinking about doing or that I wanted to
organize think about things that you
know having time you know so much of our
lives these days is so busy and
cluttered and what are the what are the
things that you would do if you had more
time is it to read is it is it maybe to
write poetry or do art what is it that
that you know has been the thing
that's in the back of your head that
clay wanted to try and do this and I've
never had time clean closet if you
didn't get bored did you ever get
restless 665 days in the Space Station
actually I did an amazing experience I I
think being part of something that's
bigger than me being part of exploration
was really really something special to
be a part of so even if I was just
cleaning the fan filtration bins it was
still keeping the space station alive
and being a part of exploration yeah
that's true all right Peggy Whitson
Peggy thank you very much meanwhile back
here on earth I've been boring my wife
terribly I told her a story about I oh
my god we've Katie's bored with you
we've got down to the level of I'm
telling you anecdotes about fifth-grade
football games and when I was governor
here in New York I think over the
weekend even said he was starting to get
annoyed at his dog all right Peggy
Whitson thank you